hi good afternoon thanks for taking time
out of this beautiful Sunday to sit and
learn about beaker I think it's about
the most exciting thing I've worked on
in almost a decade and I hope that by
the end will convince you that is
something you should at least try
so I'm Matt Greenwood by the way I guess
I should have this is Scott
I'm just the frontman Scott does all the
work and he's gonna demo beaker for you
later so in order to explain to you what
beaker actually is I've turned a little
bit of a story a little bit out what to
Sigma is and why beaker became
incredibly important for us so very
briefly you probably haven't heard of 2
Sigma 2 Sigma Investments is a large
investment manager situated about 20
blocks south of here we're a good number
of hundred people who who work in
investment management and the the
easiest metaphor for everyone in the
room is to say as Amazon is to retail so
2 Sigma is to investment management
we're fundamentally a technology company
with tens if not hundreds of Engineers
and modelers whose goal it is to figure
out the best thing that we should invest
for our customers across the globe in
order to give them a return that that we
think they're entitled to and we can get
better than anyone else or as I like to
say to my mother our job is to forecast
the future and that's what we do at 2
Sigma now 2 Sigma is really divided in
many ways into modelers and into
engineers and the modelers goal is
simply to take something that they
understand from an idea that they've
heard somewhere from a blog maybe from a
paper and turn that into reality and so
very frequently the modeler will start
off with this okay so for about 10 years
of my life as a mathematician this is
what I look at every morning every
evening most of this was in the garbage
if I was lucky I got one or two pages
that I could take home but really that's
hard and I think this this looks good
for about 20 seconds but really we need
something more structured and so
this is probably a much better way of
figuring out how stuff works it's not
surprising that this is the the
ubiquitous lab notebook those squares on
the page just that this this way of
jumping out of you and we use that
notebooks across the globe for data
science and for science in general to do
a huge amount of things so here are some
examples of lab notebooks that you'll
see and you'll see that actually the use
of lab notebooks is quite quite huge
there's a fair amount of text that's
written on some of these notebooks some
ideas maybe some things that are
important that your circle with a
highlight there's all a formatting that
goes on a lot of mathematical formatting
you'll see down in the the lower right
hand side some beautiful multimedia on
the on the left hand side and you know
maybe maybe some notes about what you
need to take home for dinner that
evening or other ideas that you might
come back to in in many months and in
many ways what we wanted to do in
technology is to be able to give our
modelers and data scientists this kind
of rich experience that they would have
on on a piece of pen and paper with a
piece of pen of paper
in but but actually in in a notebook and
so when we were thinking about 10 years
ago I've been at the company for over a
decade so about 10 years ago when we
were trying to understand what we could
give our modelers many of them have come
from a background where lots of scripts
were written in orc in Perl maybe you
know increasing numbers then in Python
far less than today a lot of the stuff
that we use regular in Python today just
just was a gleam in in people's eyes
back then and we sat and thought long
and hard over the over the years about
how we could find a paradigm that would
work both for our modelers and for us
and I mean this in two different ways
when you have a company that you expect
to grow and you want to be really good
you have to think very very forward you
have to think what am I going to need
not now but maybe in five years or in 10
years time and we were lucky or unlucky
to be kind of on the cusp
Perle was dying and python was was was
coming up the ranks and we understood
that modeling languages just like all
programming languages come and go and
therefore what we wanted to do is
provide an infrastructure that would
allow these languages to naturally come
along and dominate for a while and then
maybe drop off and so it's very
important to us to build an environment
allowed us to do so the other thing that
well that I came to this was was a quote
that I'd heard many many years ago
attributed to Charles v the holy emperor
of Rome who said that I speak Spanish to
God French to men Italian to women and
English to my horse now I I will admit
we English are a little bit horsey from
time to time but I think that there was
something much much deeper in that quote
but I'm going to appropriate from real
languages to modeling languages and that
is he was attempting to point out that
every language that exists on this earth
is really good at a couple of things
maybe it's talking to God and that was
Spanish or maybe Italian is actually the
language of love but every language can
do one thing really uniquely and that
was the other thing that we came to this
notebook with we understood that there
would be ways to write in this notebook
that you want you wouldn't want to go
back and recreate not every language can
do everything the same way as every
other language and we want to be able to
preserve the best out of every language
so that indeed the whole will be far far
greater in some of the parts or the
other way around like I apologize so we
came out with beaker beaker is the data
scientist laboratory it's a notebook
style development environment for
working interactively with complex data
sets or if you like this is the IDE for
data scientists in addition to being a
general IDE
it has a polyglot architecture but
allows you to switch between languages
and to add new ones with ease and so
what we did is we took all of those
ideas that we saw in notebooks over the
years
and we tried to implement as many of
them as we could as easy as we could in
our notebook so this is some screenshots
of what we were able to do and what
you'll see is that we have appropriated
some of the typesetting in the top right
hand side we have latex for typesetting
or down below some HTML or some markdown
there are some beautiful visualizations
and some standard rendering of tables
and this follows the standard notebook
paradigm that we all know and love from
you know from Mathematica for many years
ago input cells that are executed to
provide output cells so we've one upped
the standard notebook by allowing you to
actually execute code that you write
into the notebook akin to to just about
every other notebook on the market today
but as I said Becca is polyglot and
beaker is polyglot out of the box we
support the following languages in the
current open source distribution Python
our Giulia JavaScript groovy html5
nodejs latex Ruby and a couple of others
that aren't on actually on here and
you'll see that those roughly split into
two or maybe three different areas
firstly there are ways in which you want
to express yourself like latex or
markdown or HTML so that you can write
what you want to write because at the
end of the day when you create something
in the notebook you don't create it for
yourself you're creating it to give to
other people and you can give them you
know three thousand lines of code or you
can give them a notebook that actually
looks beautiful and speaks to them in
their language and then there is the
language of data science itself Python
our Julie R is a newcomer and
fast-growing MATLAB might be there or
octave groovy Ruby these are all
different languages that you can use to
program in order to pull out the the
insights that you want from your data
set and finally there are things like
html5 and JavaScript allow you to
manipulate the results of your data
science into something that other people
can play with some beautiful
visualization
some graphics that are simply not
available or less available because
maybe your favorite scientific language
isn't quite your favorite visualization
language and so down below there's a
classic example of what we mean so you
might have some code that you use for a
long time in Python that will allow you
to go out to websites to to pull in some
data to manipulate it to parse it and
you happen to be learning are right now
because that might be trendy to do it
might be something that you want to do
well you don't need to learn how to do
all of that in our you've got that
already baked in Python and you can
focus on understanding in are the things
that you want to do with R so you might
want to do some plotting or awesome
distributions and then finally you won't
might want to display that in a rich
format something like d3 or some other
plotting library and indeed in Piku out
of the box we have our own quite
beautiful plotting library that we get
that is contained in the distribution so
just to dive a little bit into also
translation before I turn over to Scott
to do some demos and dive even deeper
the the key piece of technology that
allows beaker to really be polyglot is
the ability to transfer data from one
cell to another so I have one Python
cell 1 JavaScript cell and you see at
the bottom what it actually looks like
we've taken care that where languages
offer the opportunity to do current meta
poke meta programming it looks quite
natural and language so here for example
at the bottom left we are setting a
beaker variable to be X in the python
cell and then using it subsequently in a
JavaScript cell again with just B
connects the way that works very briefly
is that every language simply renders
the data that it needs to save to the
notebook into a language agnostic JSON
blob that then can be read by any of the
languages that we provide and so in this
way you can not only you can pass data
all the way through your notebook from
any land
to another so let me turn out to Scott
thanks Matt so I'm going to review the
architecture and just tell you a little
bit about how beaker works and then I'm
gonna give you a live demo so here's a
pretty standard diagram you can see the
emphasis you know we're using all the
latest open source infrastructure so
like our servers implemented in Java
with jetty our client is implemented it
runs in the web browser it uses the
latest you know html5 features it's
based on angular so which is for
templating and data binding it has a
really nice sort of Model View
controller architecture so it's easy to
work in in beaker and the actual the
language is that you can run in beaker
are implemented by these back-end
servers and so and we use the standard
native backends so when you run R in
beaker or you run Python in beaker we're
accessing the the R or the Python that
you already have installed on your
computer and in particular for Python we
actually use the the ipython protocol so
that we're actually essentially in that
case where a beaker is actually like a
front-end communicating with the ipython
back-end now also on the server side we
use nginx as a reverse proxy and that
makes all the server's appear as a
single server to the client that makes
it easier to program but it's also
really useful for security because that
means the authentication and encryption
can be done in one place and that's
really useful for sort of like
institutions or sort of enterprises then
want to work they want to work with
beaker on the clients side I want to
point out one part of the architecture
in particular which are are the the
plugins so beaker has does a lot of you
know the client side is implemented in
JavaScript and so it can do dynamic
loading and we have a plug-in API for
the data that's produced and so the the
ones the main ones that we already have
our HTML the the plotting and charting
and another one is tables like
spreadsheets and you can add your own
visualization plugins if you have your
own way or a new way to visualize or
interact with data or if you just want
to you know take your favorite library
and sort of incorporate it it's pretty
easy to plug it in to beaker another
plug-in API that beak that is really
important to beaker is the one for
evaluators that is the one that sort of
implements the glue that allows beaker
to speak each language and you know
that's also JavaScript and it handles
things like auto completion and code
highlighting and it defines the protocol
that the web browser uses to communicate
with the the backend that actually
executes the code in that language so
now I'm going to switch over to the live
demo so here I've got
so here I have beaker running on my
laptop and this is a page in my you know
in my web browser you can let me just
pop it back here so you can see it's
just connected to a port running on the
local host and the first demo is to
create a random network in Python and
then visualize it with JavaScript and d3
and so here's some Python code you can
see so this is a the kind of when I say
graph it's like with note the kind that
has nodes and edges we just generate a
bunch of random connections and then we
assign the results to the beaker object
and the beaker object is the one that's
shared among all the cells and I'm also
going to actually at the very end I'm
going to return the beaker dot graph so
that we can see it oops
so you can see the the result is just an
array of dictionaries so we don't want
to really look at it too much we're
going to move on to the HTML which
divided the describes some some Styles
so we're just going to run that and then
some JavaScript and in the JavaScript
you read out the the beaker object the
beaker graph you read it into JavaScript
and then it's a bunch of sort of
standards d3 code and when you run that
you end up with a nice interactive sort
of d3 visualization of the of the graph
so the next demo is of the interactive
tables and charts so here's some Python
code that contacts Yahoo and reads out a
data frame and again I'm going to assign
it into the shared beaker object and
then just return it so that we can see
the results of it and I decided not to
rely on the internet so I have this one
sort of pre I pre ran this Sal and the
output that you get is just a nice
interactive table here you notice that
you can click on the the columns and
sort them you can do things like select
all and copy and then you know just
paste it into Excel if you want to
manipulate your data that way but really
the you know Excel is not my favorite
way of interacting with data I'm more of
a you know if you want to make a chart
like a standard time series plot we have
our own library for doing that and it
works with that library works with any J
saw it uses a JSON data structure to
specify how to turn the time series and
how to visualize it you you can create
JSON in any language but you know we
have a nice groovy API that sort of is
uh that makes it even easier so I'm just
going to use the groovy version and when
you run that you
end up with a standard price chart and
what's nice about this is it's not just
a PNG image it's actually you know
interactive so you can like look at the
with the mouse you can sort of play with
it and read values off you can drag it
and you can zoom it and actually the
nicest form of interaction is actually
sharing so let me show you that if you
go back up here you can share with just
one click and you can share any cell any
section or the whole notebook with just
one click and so again I'm not gonna
rely on the internet right now so but if
you were to click that this page comes
up and it has the same graph on it let's
show you here you know it gets uploaded
to the sharing beaker notebook com which
is a website that actually connects to
github guests similar and so anybody who
has this URL you can look and this is
just a regular web page now but what's
really cool is that the the interaction
still works so I can now is I can uh in
the shared version the the data is is
still live so now the next demo is
another is about another feature of our
plotting library is how it handles large
data sets so you know having interaction
where you can point at the line and sort
of interact with a plot and drag it and
zoom it that's all very nice but the
problem with you know working with SVG
and html5 like that is that when you
have thousands of data points your web
browser starts to run more slowly and
might even crash so here's an example
where I have two lines they're just
random walks
they have 10,000 data points each and
yet the
interaction here is still you know a
really high frame rate and that is
possible because beaker is automatically
filtering the data and so it's averaging
the the data points that would be too
close together and reducing it to a
single Dom element but the the downside
of doing that you know the upside of
doing that is that your browser doesn't
crash and you can interact with your
data the downside is that you've you've
lost some information and you might be
seeing only the average instead of all
the actual points so to to help
ameliorate that problem beaker can
instead of can replace just the line
with the actual say a box or River
representation and so now we're seeing
the average and the minimum and the
maximum of each group of points that got
filtered down to a single Dom element
and so now you can see we could week so
we can zoom all the way out we can see
all the points and we can zoom all the
way in and if you keep zooming and keep
zooming eventually you'll get to a point
where it doesn't need to filter the data
anymore there it just popped out this is
the this is the raw the raw data and if
we zoom out when you you can see and now
we can mouse over we can still see the
the min Max and an average so that's
beakers interactive plotting library and
it's a level of detail feature so the
the next demo I'm going to show you is
something that might be especially good
for this audience
so beaker being polyglot it allows it to
you know speak multiple languages and
that includes as a corollary the the
languages of Python 2 and Python 3 which
are effectively different languages and
with beaker you can actually run Python
2 in Python 3 in the same notebook and
use auto translate to
communicate between them so here's a
quick example I'm going to use the the
mechanize package which has not been
updated to work with Python 3 so but I'm
not going to again I'm not relying on
the internet so I can't run this cell
and you can see I now actually I didn't
I neglected to run it in advance though
to get the output here fortunately
because of the way the beakers this
beaker object is implemented it's not
just a way of communicating between the
cells but it actually is storing the
data in the notebook and so even though
I'm not connected to the Internet you
can see here when I ran this cell this
morning when I was connected to the
Internet it was stored in this beaker
dot URL text variable so that's still
defined no oops I got that weird problem
this is what happens when you run from
master on a development project ok so
the result of reading from the
mechanised library it's just a long
string which is the text of the notebook
we don't really want to look at that
instead what we want to do is use now
Python 3 so here you can see that this
cell is in Python 3 Python 3 has better
support for parsing unicode and just
working with strings and different
languages and you know webpages in fact
have many languages on them so this is
kind of a toy this is a toy parser but
I'm just gonna make a histogram of the
HTML tags on that web page and so once
again the output is an array of objects
and we don't really want to look at that
instead I want to visualize it so I'm
gonna run some HTML to define some
styles and I'm gonna run some d3 code
boom to create a nice little visual
of what's on that webpage okay so that's
the end of the demos and I'm gonna
switch back to PowerPoint and the next
so that's what we have working today so
how about the future there's a couple of
things that we're thinking about and
planning for and in particular
collaborative editing is something that
we're very interested in so basically
having multiple people working on the
same notebook at the same time like in
like in Google Docs we'd also like to
allow you to reconnect to a running
instance so for example to be able to
start a cell evaluating and then close
your laptop go home open your laptop
reconnect to the server and then you
know get the result of that execution a
third thing we're looking at is
improving Auto translation basically
right the improving the performance of
it so right now Auto translation is
really easy to implement but the the
data has to be copied you know between
your web browser between the backends
and so it's could be faster and so the
solution to all three of these problems
is the same it's basically we want to
move the through the main data model you
know where is the notebook stored from
your web browser into the server and
once the notebook is actually in the
cloud and is just we have just a thin
client where we're connecting to it we
can increase performance and add
features like collaborative editing and
disconnected evaluation so as a in
summary Beeker is the data scientists
laboratory it is open source it is
polyglot it's notebook based hey guys
Auto translation to communicate between
the different languages it's easy to
extend because it has a plug-in
architecture and it's easy to use
because it was you know designed with
the latest tools for people working
today so you can get it from beaker
notebook comm and it's open source so
that you can get the source code on
github we are really actively looking
for collaborators if you have your own
language that you would like to add or
your own visualization that you would
like to see work in beaker you know
please contact us or just you know if
you want to you know use it to do your
own data science you know please
download it and let us know what you
think thank you very much